PAUL IRISH: Welcome to "The
Breakpoint," episode five.
In this episode, we're going
to do a grab bag of Chrome
DevTools features.
Stuff that you probably haven't
seen, some new stuff.
But we're going to cover
all of DevTools.
So we're going to start off
doing some mobile overrides
and emulating mobile
environments while still on
your desktop machine.
We're going to transition and do
some CSS stuff, showing off
the CSS Regions support.
And we're going to get into
JavaScript, show some insight
that we have into internal
properties and bound
functions, even do some native
memory profiling.
So kind of spanning the gamut,
but showing you things that
you probably haven't seen,
some power inside your
DevTools that you'll be
excited to play with.
So to kick this off, Addy
over in London is
going to show you--
what are you showing?
Some mobile stuff?
ADDY OSMANI: I'm going
to be showing some
mobile stuff today.
But before we get started, I
wanted to wish everybody in
DevTools Land a big
happy new year!
PAUL IRISH: Oh.
ADDY OSMANI: Happy
new year pony!
PAUL IRISH: That's very nice.
That's styled console logs?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, it's
styled console log.
We showed this a couple
of episodes back.
This is all I've been playing
with during my holidays, and
now I am very, very happy
to be showing it off.
But we're going to
be talking--
PAUL IRISH: Nothing that styled
console logs can't
really augment with some
ponies and happiness.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
If you don't have ponies in your
DevTools, you're doing
something wrong.
Right.
So for the first part of this
show, we're going to be
talking about mobile.
Now increasingly, users
everywhere, regardless of what
type of app you're having, are
interested in accessing your
web apps using some sort
of mobile device.
And a lot of the time, you want
to make sure that you're
delivering them the best
experience possible.
Now from a development side of
things, this often means
either having to debug your app
using an emulator of some
sort or, even worse, having to
actually play around with a
device or multiple devices
just to see
how well things work.
So we've actually introduced a
bunch of stuff in the DevTools
to help with this workflow.
And I'm going to show you some
of this stuff today.
Now, the first tip I'm going to
give you before we actually
start playing around with this a
lot is that you can actually
debug or try out how different
layouts look.
So if you're using, say, media
queries, for example, to offer
people different layouts and
adaptive layouts for your
apps, you can actually use
DevTools in doc to write mode.
And you can just use the slider
to actually increase
how much of the page
is visible.
And if you keep on moving the
slider, you can actually see
different versions of your
layout depending on the
different breakpoints you have
set up in your media queries,
which is kind of nice.
But what we're going
to be talking about
next is actually overrides.
So probably in the first episode
of "The Breakpoint" we
mentioned that we've got a ton
of override capabilities
available if you have the
DevTools Experiments enabled.
And we're going to talk
through some of these.
Now let's say, for example, that
you want to see how your
web app might look if
you're on iOS and
perhaps on an iPhone.
Now, if you pop open DevTools
and go to Overrides--
which is in the Settings
cog, so click down in
the Settings cog--
go to Overrides and select
User Agent first of all.
And then select a device.
So we have a ton of device
names available here.
We've got iPads, iPhones,
Android devices and a ton of
other stuff.
Now if I select, for example,
iPhone with iOS 5, what you'll
see has happened is it's
actually gone and re-sized my
view port so that I can
see what this might
look like on an iPhone.
Now I haven't had to pop open
an emulator of any sort.
I can just see directly inside
Chrome what this looks like.
What you'll see below this is
that we've got a section
called Device Metrics, which
will tell you what screen
resolution is displaying for
your app at the moment.
Now you can manually go and
customize these details as
much as you want.
It'll also try emulating the
font scale factor, so it will
show how your fonts might
look in that device too.
But it's very, very easy
to go and switch
between device types.
So if I wanted to switch and go
to a Nexus S, for example,
I can do that.
As you can see, the layout
on my web app has
automatically changed.
And it's just a very easy way of
seeing how your app or site
might look on a different
device, which is kind of neat.
Now, another thing that you're
going to be dealing with a lot
of the time on mobile are things
like touch events.
And touch events
are difficult.
I'm going to throw open
a quick touchdown.
And now this is something
Paul created.
Paul, you created this
a while back.
This is like a little finger
painting demo.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, it stemmed
because I got this question.
Someone was like, can we do a
multi-touch application with
canvas on the web?
'Cause everyone thought that
you couldn't properly do
multi-touch.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: And so this was a
little demo to show that you
can in fact track multiple touch
points on the web, and
it's not a problem.
So it works.
ADDY OSMANI: That's
pretty neat.
So what I'm doing at the moment
inside this canvas area
is I'm actually trying to
drag my cursor around.
And what you'll see is that
nothing's really happening,
because this demo actually
relies on touch events, which
you'll probably find in a mobile
device but currently
not on the system I'm
using at the moment.
So what I can do in DevTools
is go back to my Overrides.
And near the bottom, you'll see
an option called Emulate
Touch Events.
Now if I check this and I go
and I reload this app--
so it should be reloaded--
I should now be able to go and
draw using touch events.
So whoa!
Wow, this is insane.
I love this.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: Aah!
And that's awesome.
Again, it means that you don't
have to go and pop open a
device or an emulator to try
getting this working, which is
pretty cool.
What's also nice is that not
only are you going to get
touch events working when you're
trying out demos or
trying out bits and pieces
of code, but if you use
Modernizr, as so many people do,
you can actually emulate.
So I'm in a different tab, I'm
going to make sure that
Emulate Touch Events
is in here.
What you can see at the moment
is this is using
Modernizr.touch to check if
there's touch event support
available locally.
Now what you'll see in the first
column is On Touchstart
isn't present.
If we were to scroll across,
we'd see that On Touchend is
also not available.
Now we can actually
emulate this.
So if I were to just reload this
page, you should now see
that On Touchstart is available
in window, and On
Touchend is also
available too.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, and actually
you're running Canary here,
aren't you?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, yeah.
I'm running Canary.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, because it was
like two days ago, one of
the last ones--
I think it's Window.touch
maybe?
That was also added
to the list.
So it is removed as a global
constructor when Touch is not
available to the browser.
ADDY OSMANI: Nice.
PAUL IRISH: So the detector that
Modernizr uses here is On
Touchstart?
ADDY OSMANI: Mm hmm.
PAUL IRISH: Detecting to see
if that event handler
attribute is bound.
But some other people
use other things.
Anyways, the touch story for
future detection in WebKit now
is really nice.
So we'll actually probably be
publishing an article pretty
soon on how to detect touch,
all the different types of
touch event models, and deal
with that pretty soon.
ADDY OSMANI: Sweet.
So we've talked about
touch, we've talked
about device metrics.
The next thing we're going
to be talking about is
orientation.
Now because mobile devices
offer us a few other
capabilities, like being able
to tilt the device in
different directions or
accelerate the device
depending on how you're actually
moving it, that gives
us a whole range of other
capabilities we can build into
our apps so that we can react
on them depending on what
someone's doing.
Now, again, this is usually
something that you'd have to
be using a device to test on
or an emulator to test on.
But again, we've got support
for this stuff inside the
DevTools to make your debugging
workflow a little
bit more easy.
So I've currently got a HTML5
Rocks orientation demo open at
the moment.
And if we look at Overrides
once again, you'll see a
section called Override
Device or Orientation.
Now, what this allows me to
set is a few different
parameters to finding what
direction the devices is in,
what acceleration the device
has got, is it being tilted
from the side, is it being
tilted from the
front and so on.
And I'm just going to show
you how this works.
So let's say that I'm changing,
I guess it's the
vertical acceleration.
Let's say that I
set this to 60.
What you'll see is that this
is gone and it's actually
changed the acceleration that's
being shown on screen
for this particular demo.
And I haven't had to go and open
up a separate device to
try to test it out.
Let's go back to the
Overrides and let's
play around with tilts.
So let's say that I
change that to 50.
What you can see is this is
probably what it would look
like if I was holding
a device this way.
But it just means that you
can go and test out those
different directions and
orientations that you want
someone to be able to do things
with inside your app
just using the DevTools in
Chrome, which is, again, a
nice little time saver.
So another thing I'm going to
show you right before we look
at a few things like CSS
regions, is something that was
added I think just before
Christmas, wasn't it?
Emulating CSS media types.
So emulating CSS media
types is pretty cool.
And I'm going to be using
"Smashing Magazine" as an
example of this.
So we're going to go to
"Smashing Magazine," going to
pop open the DevTools,
going to go
straight back to Overrides.
And at the very bottom, you've
got an option that says
Emulate CSS Media.
Now, the thing that this is
really useful for is actually
seeing what your different
media style sheet
types might look like.
So at the moment, I'm
emulating the
CSS media print type.
And you can see, this is pretty
much what "Smashing
Magazine" would look like
if you were to go
and print it out.
You can see that all of the
links have been normalized to
a more readable type of text.
They've dropped some of the
different styles and colors
and images from their page.
And it just means that you can
see what your different style
sheets for different media types
might look like without
even having to go and debug with
a different page or add
any custom code to switch
those things.
And it's, again, a nice
little time saver.
So I'm not sure what other types
they might have on this
page, so you can also
try out handheld.
So it looks like "Smashing
Magazine" has a media type
enabled for handheld, so
I can see how that
might look as well.
And it's, again, one more thing
that you can use to try
saving you some time.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
On this one, I would just go in
the DOM view and find the
style sheet for print, and just
change media equals print
to media equals screen.
And it'll fake it.
But this is proper print
application, which may even
take advantage of some of the
print specific styles like
page break before.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: But anyways, it's
certainly a lot handier to
check your print styles.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
And that's definitely
something that can
save you some time.
Now, the next thing we're going
to be taking a look at
is CSS Regions.
Now while I'm opening up the
DevTools, Paul do you want to
explain what CSS Regions are,
just to remind people?
PAUL IRISH: Sure.
So CSS Regions basically allow
magazine style layout.
And what this means is you can
define your layout of text.
So I have a div here and I have
a big picture right next
to it and then three columns
of text underneath it.
And so you can really have a lot
of control over the exact
layout of your boxes
of images and text.
Now, currently, CSS multi-column
allows you to
split up text into columns.
But it doesn't allow things like
dealing with this kind of
magazine style layout.
It's more just the simplistic
I want things in columns.
So Regions lets you define these
boxes just using divs.
And then you basically say, I
have a big div full of text.
Please have this text run
through these boxes around the
side of the image.
And it just flows through and
deals with the breaking into
words as things fit.
So it allows you to have very
good control on the size,
layout, et cetera, using any
sort of CSS that you want, and
then you can just flow
text through it.
ADDY OSMANI: Cool.
So the demo that we've
got open at the
moment is one from Adobe.
The title of this is "Adaptive
layout with Media Queries and
CSS Regions".
And basically what happens is
once I actually re-size this
page, what you'll see is that
the text content is going to
start flowing between
different columns.
And this is using a combination
of Media Queries
and CSS Regions to happen.
Now, inside the DevTools, if you
want to get the ability to
actually inspect the different
regions inside your CSS
Regions page, is you can go to
Experiments, and there's an
option here that says
CSS Regions Support.
So you enable that, go and
you refresh your page.
Now, let's say that I want to
select something in here.
It can really be anything.
Let's inspect an element here.
We've got a paragraph.
Now, when I right-click on the
DOM element that I've selected
and I go to a new place called
CSS Named Flows, what will
happen is a new panel is going
to open up at the very bottom
that's going to basically
describe all of the different
regions that describe
this layout.
So what you can see is we've got
a region chain describing
region one and region two.
There are two specific regions
inside this page.
It'll also display the content
for specific regions if you
want to dive down into that.
And what's really nice is you
can actually go and select a
region and it will reveal the
elements in the Elements pane
that make up this region.
So I can go and I can dive down
into these and further
style them if I want,
and just debug them,
which is quite nice.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, I like that.
And so we should point out that
this cool patch, this
feature was added to
the DevTools by
Adobe contributed this.
Addy, do you want to show how
to enable this feature?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, of course.
So once again, you have to be
inside the Settings cog.
Go down to Experiments, and
enable it using the CSS Region
Support option inside
Experiments.
And then all you have to do is
just refresh your page, and
you should be able to start
inspecting CSS Region based
content and just going and
seeing the CSS named flows
inside of there.
Cool, so--
PAUL IRISH: Am I going to
show some stuff now?
ADDY OSMANI: I think
you're going to be
showing some stuff.
I was going to show the
selector highlighting.
Do you want to show that?
PAUL IRISH: Sure,
I'll do that.
ADDY OSMANI: All right.
PAUL IRISH: All right.
So we'll come over to me.
And the first thing that we're
going to take a look at is the
newish selector highlight.
So here's an example here.
I've just selected this Run
button up inside jsFiddle.
And on the right-hand side,
we have my styles.
And this happens a lot where you
create a big style chain
of selectors and then you're
applying some things to it.
And so in this case, we're
just applying some common
things to all buttons.
But sometimes it's a little
hard to see exactly which
selector that you
authored matches
this particular element.
So now it's just a little bit
more clear that this element
in black is the actual
one in this case
that the DOM matches.
So it should be helpful.
I think Oliver J. Ash,
a developer in the
UK, requested this.
And then I was like,
file a ticket!
And then he did, and within
a day it was in the Tool.
So it was a fantastic feature
request, and I think it's much
better now that we have
that in there.
ADDY OSMANI: That's amazing.
It's also a good reminder for
people that want to get new
features lined in in
DevTools to just go
to crbug.com, right?
PAUL IRISH: crbug.com/new.
File it, ping Addy or me and
we'll take a look and try and
make it happen.
All right, so now that we've
seen the mobile side of
things, the CSS side of
things, we're going to
transition into a little
bit of JavaScript.
So I'm over here in jsFiddle,
and the JavaScript that I have
up on the screen right now is
basically a way to look at how
closures operate.
So we have an external function
called A. Inside of
that, we have a little array,
which takes the arguments
passed into A. And then what A
eventually ends up returning
is another function,
which we're
internally calling B here.
And all that's going to return
is the index of this trapped
array that was passed in.
So we will construct a
new function here by
passing in Here I Am.
This will return a function
into our B. And then if we
call B passing an index value,
we should see that.
So if we run this, we log to
the console the I from the
middle, because we're
logging out the one.
That makes sense.
But a lot of times, your
applications are a bit more
complicated than this, but
you're still dealing with this
kind of concept.
So we have some new features
inside the debugger that allow
you to see this a bit better.
So if I just hit Run so I can
trap this again, I'm trapping
with the debugger
keyword here.
And I'm going to add a new
watch expression up here,
which is B. And a new thing that
you're going to be seeing
here is this new function
scope expando.
So you open that up, and you
can see the closure that is
inside of your B variable.
So this is the little
function.
And then inside there, you can
see that the array was trapped
and you can inspect it.
So here you're able to
investigate the scope within
that function and see what is
captured within that closure,
which in a lot of cases is
really, really useful.
And we're able to explore that
from the object itself, rather
than looking only at what's
inside, say, the scope
variables, which is a different
approach to look at this.
All right.
So that's one new one.
And then another new thing.
So first I'm going to explain
the JavaScript.
We have a little summing
function.
It takes two arguments
and it sums them.
Makes sense.
Then we're going to take that
summing function and we're
going to use function prototype
bind and bind it to
a null scope and an
argument of one.
OK, and we're going to
save that function
into the INC variable.
So now I'm going to
run this again.
Great.
And again, I set up some watch
expressions so we can see a
little bit of what's
going on here.
So there's two things to note.
One is that inside sum we
immediately see what the
function value of sum is,
which is pretty useful.
I should point out that you can
always right-click here
and jump to the function
definition,
which is right here.
But I'm broken, so it's
a little funny.
But then our bound function,
which we use right here, we
can't actually see what
the source of it is.
It is a native function because
we used function
prototype bind, so we can't
actually see what's going on.
But if we open up the function,
we have these new
properties down here so we
see the target function.
So this is the function that
was bound using function
prototype bind.
We can investigate that just
the exact same way.
And we can also see what this
argument, what was passed in
as the first argument to
function bind, which was null,
which we passed up right here,
and any arguments.
So our arguments array just has
a single argument, which
is one, which we passed
right here.
So here at run time, we're able
to see a lot more insight
around functions that were bound
with any new scopes and
new arguments, which gives
a lot more insight
into how this works.
ADDY OSMANI: That's awesome.
PAUL IRISH: All right, cool.
Next, we're going to come over
to the Google homepage,
because I'm going to show
native memory profiling.
So just pop open the DevTools.
And over on the Profiles page,
what I'm about to show is
another experiment, which you
can just enable over here in
the Experiments.
I keep them all enabled pretty
much always, but I don't know
if I recommend that.
There's a big red warning at the
top of this, so that's up
for you to decide.
But if you have them
all enabled, you're
going to see this guy.
So this is a live updating chart
of their memory usage.
And you're also going to get
this native memory snapshot.
So I'm going to take one of
these, because it gives a
little bit more insight.
So I take it, I view
it over here.
And here we can get a little
bit more insight into the
actual memory consumption
of the page.
So 32% of it is captured by the
JavaScript heap itself.
And we can investigate more
about that over in the actual
heap profile.
Looks like the inspector--
the DevTools--
are using 9.2% of the memory,
and we can see
how that lays out.
The page structures and the in
memory CSS DOM stuff that
WebKit and WebCore is using,
and everything else.
So this is really useful if you
are also working with the
heap profiler and trying to
identify where your memory's
being consumed.
This is currently still
an experiment.
It's getting more commits
every day.
So things might break, but this
is a good little preview
at this new feature.
Next, we have another
new feature in
the JavaScript profiler.
And this is the ability to see
the difference between idle
time and time that is
spent elsewhere.
So previously, if you ran a
JavaScript profile, you might
notice that a lot of the time
in your CPU profile was
consumed by "program".
And I would try and identify why
my JavaScript was so slow,
but at the same time, v8's
really fast and most of the
time is spent elsewhere.
So this mysterious program
block would consume maybe
about 95% of my time.
I didn't really know
what was going on.
So here we have a little bit
more of a better idea.
So this demo here is this kind
of cool, it's like Parallax.
I think there's a [INAUDIBLE].
But I really like this kind
of effect, this 3D layers
emerging effect.
On the video, I think you might
be able to see this,
it's kind of chunky,
these transitions.
And so I saw this yesterday and
I was trying to figure out
why it was so chunky.
I go over to Timeline,
I start recording.
And I'm recording and these
frames are huge.
These frames are absolutely
massive.
But at the same time, we're
busting way above our 30 FPS,
but they're not really filled
with anything too useful.
So then I was like, maybe
it's in the CPU profile?
So I'm going to collect
a new CPU
profile and move it around.
Get a little bit of action
there, come back.
And here's the most useful part
that we have, which is
any sort of idle time, which is
just captured by CPU's not
busy at all, is clearly
called out as idle.
Before, we didn't have this
inside Chrome, so it's great
to have that very explicit.
Program, when you see this now,
this basically means the
browser was busy, the CPU was
busy doing other things.
Busy doing things in other tabs
or something that we just
don't know about.
We know it was busy, and so we
can say it might have slowed
down other things.
You shouldn't expect to see
Program now at around 90.
If it does, it means your page
might be slowing down, but
it's not this page's fault.
And then of course, any other
JavaScript on the page you can
investigate.
So anyways, small thing.
It gives a lot better insight
into what's actually going on.
All right, WebSockets.
Addy, if you can join me over
here on this little demo?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, I will.
PAUL IRISH: All right, so
before, we've been able to see
that there are WebSockets and
they are connected in the
Network panel.
We can just select WebSockets
and see that there is a socket
connection.
And now we can also see what
that actual data is.
So I can say--
you said, "Hai." Hi Addy!
All right, send me
one more message?
Nice.
All right, cool.
So inside this little Frames
view, we're able to see what
the actual data that's sent
over the WebSocket is.
I should point out that right
now when you want to get this
updating, you have to click
again on the element on the
left-hand side for the
frames to update.
We will be fixing this soon.
You just have to deal with
it for now just to
get the live view.
But you can investigate exactly
what data is going
over the WebSocket, which can
help a lot when you're
debugging the situation.
While we're on the topic of
network, a cool thing that you
can identify now that most
people don't recognize is you
can find out what kicked
off a network request.
So I'm on Amazon right now.
I'm going to bring up Network
and I'm going
to refresh the page.
All right, so Amazon--
only 1.7 megs.
Man, they are professionals.
All right, so looks good.
There's a lot going on here.
We can see a timeline and we can
re-sort this by how long
things took, or just view
the normal waterfall.
But in the middle is this
Initiator column.
And we can identify why
the browser is making
this request at all.
So let's say this
one right here--
the CSS--
is being requested because
of the parser,
which is the HTML parser.
And we can click through and
identify exactly where the
request came from,
so this link tag.
So this helps a lot of times.
Sometimes you'll just see this
request go on a network or
come through a proxy, and you'll
be like, why is this
file ever being requested?
You can find out why.
So that one's coming
from the HTML.
That one's pretty easy.
But a better example might be
this one's coming from script.
This is a little navigation
image.
Looks like a sprite.
And it's actually being
requested by a script from
inside of jQuery, so we can
see the full call stack--
this call stack was added
last week, in fact--
and then find out what's
going on inside here.
So anyways, that gives a good
amount of insight into why
these requests are going on.
So if you have a stray request
that you want to track down,
it's a lot easier these days.
I think the last two things I'm
going to show are part of
the console.
So one of the issues that we had
a little bit ago was that
our console logs inside the
Chrome DevTools, they logged
very fast, but actually when
there was a complex object
coming in, it would reveal the
exact value of that object
only when you expanded
the little arrow.
So I'm going to show an example
here where I take an
array, I kind of decrement the
values inside the array, and I
log out the array each
time I do that.
So right now, we actually get
a little preview now.
Before, this would just say
"object" and it would have
that arrow and you
look into it.
Now you'll get a preview.
So this preview is generated
at run time.
But if you open it,
it'll actually
be the current values.
So that's why this might look a
little bit confusing to you.
You might see negative 1, 1, and
2 in the preview, and then
negative 1's down here
in the live view.
So that's just the way to keep
in mind of how this works now.
So it gets snapshotted and
logged out in preview, but
when you expand it, it
is the current value.
So I'm happy now that we have
this preview and it's a lot
more functional than just the
term "object", I think.
All right, the last one inside
the console is $_.
I believe this comes
from Pearl.
The underscore refers to the
last computed value.
So back on the Google homepage,
I have this element
selected in the search box.
And I want to find out
the width of it.
Cool, so hey there.
$0?
Come on!
Nice!
All right.
So $0.offsetWidth.
So the width of this
box is 606.
What I'm going to do is add
200 to that, so 806.
And now I'd just like to make
that the new width.
So I'm just going to say, set
the new style of the box to be
that computed value.
Let me bump this font size
up a little bit.
That computed value plus
the term pixels.
And now we grew it
out our text box.
ADDY OSMANI: Nice.
PAUL IRISH: So we're just
referencing whatever was the
last computed value.
I'm going to change this
back down to minus 500
from what it is now.
So we're going to have a
computed value of 308.
And then just use that
and jump down.
So this is really handy if
you're doing anything complex,
doing any math or doing anything
else in the console
and just want to reference the
last thing that was there.
It could be an object.
Let's say I'm selecting $0 for
this form, and I could
reference the style
object of the
element that I just logged.
It's up to you.
And I think, actually, we'll
have this as part of a new set
of docs for the Chrome
DevTools, as
this is a new feature.
This will be included in the
docs that we are putting out
pretty soon, Addy?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes, pretty soon.
Hopefully in the next
couple of weeks.
PAUL IRISH: Not bad.
So you're going to be able to
check out the full range of
what's available inside the
Chrome DevTools console and a
bunch of other stuff for the
new refresh documentation
experience that I think
you'll like.
All right.
Addy, are we done on this?
Did we cover--
ADDY OSMANI: I think
we're done.
Right before we go, I just
wanted to give a shout out to
two Chrome DevTools extensions
that have
recently gotten updates.
I'm going to flip over to my
screen really quickly.
So the first one is RailsPanel,
which I saw over
on Plus a few days ago.
But basically, RailsPanel is a
Chrome DevTools extension that
gives you lots of insights into
things like rendering
times, requests, and a
lot of information
specific to Rails apps.
So Rails developers will
love using DevTools
for their front ends.
This is just a really great
extension for getting more
information about what's going
on in your application.
Another one that's gotten some
nice updates recently is
AngularJS Batarang.
We've briefly showed it while I
was flipping through on one
of our other episodes.
But basically, Batarang gives
you insights into your models
and directives, and it helps you
profile your angular wraps
so you can help improve the
performance of your apps
pretty well there.
And yeah, that's it.
PAUL IRISH: Looking good.
All right, we'll see
you guys next time.
ADDY OSMANI: See
you next time.
PAUL IRISH: Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]